thank you so much
welcome to this press conference the
president of the European Council and of
the European commission are joined by
President zielinski of Ukraine welcome
Mr President thank you so much
you have translation on channel three
president of the European Council you
have the flow first Mercy Mercy
thank you very much indeed Mr President
Vladimir zelensky Madam president of the
European commission this is a meeting
of a quite exceptional nature in the
framework of the European Council which
took place this morning this is a
meeting
at which
many of us felt a very strong sense of
emotion because we all remember the
European Council the extraordinary
European Council which took place on the
24th of February last year just a few
hours
after the outbreak of the Russian
invasion of Ukraine and indeed we spoke
virtually
president zenski spoke to the 27 heads
of Satan government we all remember the
very striking words that you used and
speaking about the destiny of your
country and of your own destiny this
meeting on 24th of February last year
represented very probably a turning
point in European history we immediately
understood
on the part of all Europeans and of the
27 leaders that we were facing a new
chapter in European history and European
security and this meant that very
quickly we had to realize how essential
Unity is it made us
understand that we had to show a strong
Firm support for the Ukrainian people
which through you embodied by you
decided to resist to fight and to fight
for the future of your people of your
country of your children and to resist
uh in a very powerful way to defend the
values of the European project Freedom
democracy human dignity for every human
individual at this press conference I'm
not going to repeat
all the measures that have already been
put in place I will focus on three main
points which I think should fully
mobilize Us in the coming days and weeks
and then I will say a make a brief
conclusion after these three points we
understand that over the coming weeks
and months
these will be of No Doubt of decisive
importance and because these coming
weeks are so important we must remain
open-eyed Lucid we must continue to
provide maximum level of support and I
can see three main areas where we need
to do that in the military field we have
spoken about this on many occasions over
recent weeks
with your meeting with President Van Der
Lyon and during the European Council you
were able to make your points in very
clear and straightforward terms to the
European leaders and of course you will
have had and will have some informal
contacts as well talking about the your
military needs what you need to help you
defend and protect the Integrity of your
of Ukraine artillery Munitions defense
systems
and this you have told us exactly what
you need and what you need now that's
the first point secondly you come here
with an a message
concerning the peace formula and I would
just say that in this respect the
European Union wants to be at your side
and to bring to the International
Community a clear determination to
respect international law the U.N
Charter and the sovereignty of Ukraine
we will spared no efforts day after day
to carry on this diplomatic and
political battle at all in all
International foreign we want to see how
it is possible to organize a summit for
a piece we must not we're fully aware
that we cannot allow ourselves to back
down to be intimidated we must be
inspired by the courage of the Ukrainian
people and a third point I wanted to
mention
I spoke that I spoke about this a few
days ago in cave you have chosen you
have followed the choice of the
Ukrainian people a free and Sovereign
Choice which was already expressed on
the maidan to turn towards freedom and
Democrat and democracy and the European
Destiny you have asked for candidacy
status in the European Union and I think
we can be very proud of the fact that
the European leaders decided so quickly
to Grant candidate status to Ukraine for
EU membership since then despite the
ongoing War you have
bravely and with great determination
implemented reforms we are very
impressed with all the progress that has
been made in just a few months
we know
that after the summer there will be a
report from the European commission my
responsibility will be to ensure that
the council lives up to its
responsibilities by the end of this year
on the basis of the commission report we
can decide on the follow-up to this
integration process for Ukraine in the
European Union these are the three main
messages
Military Support political diplomatic
support and support for Ukraine's
European Destiny and just by way of
conclusion I would just say that the
European Union
will maintain its determination to put
pressure on the Kremlin sanctions are
still on the table the tense sanctions
packages being discussed we want to take
a consistent and firm approach
we want to ensure that those were guilty
of crimes can be held to account for
those crimes including for the crime of
aggression and that is why we have the
initiatives to collect evidence and
proof so that we can enable
International Justice to remove the
impunity in this respect we want to
ensure that we can also take the
appropriate measures with regard to the
Frozen acid is only fair that these
Frozen Russian assets be used to rebuild
Ukraine and to provide Fair uh
compensation to Ukraine president
zielinski in addressing your European
counterparts you refer to the founding
fathers of the European Union these key
Personalities in the wake of the second
world war who dreamed up this European
project this new promise promising
future for Europeans who had been
traumatized by the two tragic War Wars
which had devastated the European
continent all of us here
through our families our parents our
great our grandparents who lived through
the horrors of the second world war we
they saw the European project peace and
prosperity as the key to a better future
these are the key to our European
project and
Our Generation your generation now have
come together around this common goal
this common Destiny we need to take the
right decisions to ensure that peace and
prosperity can remain the key values of
the European project
and that these can hold sway across all
of Europe in the coming decades we are
absolutely determined and I would just
say in conclusion speaking here in
Brussels I would like to repeat what I
said a few weeks ago in addressing the
Ukrainian Parliament and and the
Ukrainian people the European Union is
Ukraine Ukraine is the European Union
the European Union is our common home
and we will mobilize all our efforts to
keep this promise Slava Ukraine
The Long Live Europe
president zielinski you have the floor
Dear Mr President of the European
Council dear Osama
dear ladies and gentlemen dear
journalists
today is 361st day
and
we have had the national anthem
and the support of Ukraine today Ukraine
is fighting Ukraine can protect its
independence and the European freedom
dear Charles dear president thank you
very much for inviting me
thank you very much for allowing me to
take part in the meetings and I feel
it's only fair that Ukraine takes part
in the meetings of the European leaders
the Ukrainian language
is part of the European discussion
Ukrainian language is part of the
European Parliament and that is a part
indeed of the European practice when
Ukraine will be a part of the European
Union
dear Ursula oh dear president I would
like to thank you for the joint efforts
of the Ukrainian government and the
European commission and cave
in our state where we discussed not just
our issues of Defense but our future
our movement and our integration
our real life
of their defense and protection of our
everyday life and every and our values
I'm absolutely sure that not just
Ukrainian but the European values as
well I have just participated in the
meeting of the European Council yes it
was a closed meeting but I want you to
understand this and to get the feeling
of what we discussed and this sense was
defined by one of the leaders of the
European Union who said that the
long-term peace in Europe will only
happen when Ukraine will gain the
Victory and will become the members
member of the European Union this is the
unity we've managed to build the unity
which means that the European Union will
be with us until the victory of Ukraine
and Ukraine will become the part of the
European Union our discussions in
Brussels
have been very concrete very precise we
were talking about security we were
talking about this saving lives and
stability we were talking about the
return of Justice
and these values are not just Ukrainian
values they're European values as well
and we have discussed this and Ukraine
used to export the electricity to the
European Union
we were making your social life your
welfare
dependent on that but Russia has
occupied and switched from the network
our nuclear power station that is the
violation of your interests values yes
but also the interests and we can talk
about every single element of the
Russian aggression in the same way yes
they are trying to destroy our economy
and our cities but they're doing in such
a way that it should affect all the
Europeans we are very grateful to you
for our air defense systems but also I
would like to stress this is in the
interest of all of us not just
ukrainians but all the Europeans that
Russia should not make new missiles that
Russia should not attack our cities so
we have to move to another stop and
introduce the sanctions against the
Drone the UAV and the missile industry
of Russia and also the part of their I.T
sector which gives provisions and
support to the Russian Terror then awake
and reduce the destruction and we can
remove and the source of our defense of
our dangerous attacks
I have been very inspired by your
statements that Europe will be with us
until our Victory I've heard it from a
number of the European leaders and I'm
very grateful to them for this I've
heard about the Readiness to give us the
necessary weapons and support including
the aircrafts and I will have a number
of bilaterals now and we are going to
raise the issue of the fighter jets and
other aircraft so we are working and
continue to work in Brussels I want to
thank all of you
for I wanted to thank the European
citizen the citizens of the European
Union for all your support
for the way you support our people for
giving us the ref giving the Refuge and
the shelter for the Ukrainian citizens
who were trying to protect their
children from the bombs millions of our
citizens are Now supported in Europe and
I hope that your citizens could see that
the European values are real thank you
very much for this thank you for
everything friends
that's the only way I can address your
friends thank you and glory to Ukraine
[Applause]
thank you Mr President Madam president
you have a flaw thank you very much Mr
President
thank you thank you for coming to the
heart of the European Union
thank you for the strong message we
heard from you
your fight is a fight for independence
for democracy for free Europe
and I did not only hear your strong and
powerful message in the European
Parliament but also here in the European
Council
and I heard your urgency
we all heard the urgency of your call to
support Ukraine now
you spoke in a very moving manner
about and praising the European way of
life
and you added that ukrainians want to
come home to this European way of life
and indeed today you see we are one
family
we have one vision
and family members help each other
you can count on us
we will continue to provide our full
support
now
to sustain your people through this
atrocious war and for the future
ukrainians are giving their lives for
free and independent Ukraine
they are fighting for the respect of our
common values
and we know that we can never match the
sacrifices ukrainians are making every
single day
but we can stand up for you
one figure that puts it into perspective
is 67 billion
67 billion of support we have mobilized
in the last 12 months from budget
support to fast recovery from energy
Supply to military capabilities from
humanitarian Aid to Refugee support and
we must do more
this I think is also the urgency we took
away today as a message from you and we
must do more we are supporting Ukraine
to win this war
and we're making sure that Ukraine wins
the peace that will come
it must be a just peace
we fully back your peace formula Diva
Vladimir
the European Union is working with its
Partners to support Ukraine across the
10 points of your peace formula
from Economic Security on nuclear safety
food security energy among others
and we will work hard to ensure the
broadest possible Global support for it
a just piece also means accountability
this brings me to my second Point Russia
must pay for the destruction caused
and for the blood spilled
in the next days we will propose the
10th package of sanctions
first we will impose sanctions on a
number of political and military leaders
but also the evolutomir we listened very
carefully to your messages when we
visited you last week in Kiev
we will Target Putin's propagandists
because their lies
are poisoning the public space in Russia
and abroad you were insisting on that we
hear you we will follow up and we are
going after them
secondly the package will include
additional exports ban worth more more
than 10 billion euros this will further
starve Russia's military machine and
continue to shake the foundation of its
economy
and the International Community is also
working hard to ensure that Justice is
served
three steps are important
the first one is that we collect and
store evidence of the crimes being
committed we have already started
the second step is
to have prosecutors work together
for that we are setting up the center in
The Hague
and the next step is
to set up a Tribunal
here the discussions are ongoing about
the exact structure but I assure you
volatomir
we have the political will
to hold the perpetrator accountable
including
for the crime of aggression
and there is the political will so we
must find a way
finally
on our common future
Ukraine's youth is fighting for their
sovereign country
too many are paying the ultimate price
but their dreams lives on
dreams of a new Ukraine not only free
Democratic and European but also fair
and green and prosperous
we are already laying the groundwork
we have built the Reconstruction
platform
with which has gone live now
our partners start seconding experts to
the Secretariat
which we are hosting in Brussels and in
Kiev
the response to our call is amazing our
cities are joining too
36 European cities from villainous to
Venice will work with 10 cities in
Ukraine like khakif and Hef
this is the living proof of the enormous
support you have all over the European
Union
and as you said every single person
counts you said it very powerfully in
the European Parliament it's us the
politicians yes but every single person
in the European Union counts
to contribute to support Ukraine
Ukraine has Advantage advancing on its
urine European path in an impressive
manner
accession is a merits-based process
and your track record shows
that you are able to deliver fast
and of high quality
even as you fight an aggressor even as
you are at War
I hear Ukrainian people so often speak
about their hopes
they want their children to grow up in
the European Union
and this hope gives them the strength to
cope with this horrible War
between now
and this bright future
there may be a hard Road To Tread but
rest too short
that we will be with you along every
step of the way
let's turn ukrainian's dreams into
reality
into the European way of life
and since the beginning of my mandate
I have concluded every single speech
with the words Long Live Europe
since one year for good purpose
we add to the term long live Europe
always Slava ukrainia
[Applause]
thank you madam presidents we'll take a
few questions first but from the
Ukrainian media zoriana you had a
question from Radio free Europe
good afternoon everyone so obviously my
first question is to Ukrainian president
so if you don't mind colleagues I will
switch into Ukrainian language
we have seen the result of your visit to
Britain after this the British prime
minister has announced the training for
Ukrainian Pilots so that by the time
Ukraine could potentially get the
fighter jet they will be trained to
prepare that was quite a concrete
announcement and when you met in Paris
where the chairman Chancellor and French
president there were no concrete
promises does it mean that they were not
announced publicly or they didn't happen
so perhaps you could share those
decisions with us and also you've had
the meeting with 27 leaders of the
European Union and also the
representatives of the European
institutions we understand that you your
priority was indeed to find a
breakthrough solution for the Ukraine
together fighter jets and also
long-range missiles has Ukraine got any
closer after this meeting that was
representative question to the Ukrainian
president
European commission I would like to
address you so you mentioned this topic
apart from the weapon another crucial
topic raised here is the future
membership of Ukraine in the European
Union so as far as we know the first
official assessment of the
implementation of seven criteria is
about to come in the late 2023 and
Ukraine Council getting the decision on
opening the accession talks the same
year I mean 2023 so how could you
estimate the old Center the
possibilities to open the accession
talks especially in 2023 and is it
possible that in addition to these seven
so-called conditions would be added new
ones thank you
can answer okay
long long question
I will answer in Ukraine in Ukraine and
if it's possible um
I think that our visit to London uh has
a chance results and we have moved
towards the dissolutions concerning the
long-range missiles and the training of
our Pilots yes indeed that is an
important road to getting the fighter
jets which we need also there are
certain agreements which are not public
but are positive
and when uh these items will happen in
our state uh our state will know this
but I don't want to prepare the Russian
Federation which constantly threads us
with the new aggression concerning Paris
and the meeting with the president
macro and Chancellor Schultz we had
I would say a very powerful meeting
a very important meeting and
I see this meeting as a positive one and
talking about concrete decisions indeed
I would not want to announce many things
publicly but all I can say is that we
were working towards the enhancement of
our capabilities when we talk about the
offensive we are talking about the
equipment and we are talking about the
tanks and I have received a positive
impression from our meeting
when we talk about the meeting with the
27 leaders
well first of all we have to understand
that Britain France earned 27 countries
of the EU and the European Union and the
leadership and indeed the Society of the
European Union
all deserve a huge gratitude from us
from our state so one of the reasons why
I'm here is I have to thank for all the
figures for all the words which were
mentioned in concrete steps which were
mentioned today these are the concrete
measures to support our society and to
support our displaced citizens and our
economy as well that all supported our
resilience resilience of the state means
the Army and the Army Brazilian Army
means the Victory and that is of course
the only result we all see
and thanks God for that talking about
the results of the meeting uh when we
talk about the meetings we indeed
took place we still have a number of
bilaterals we are working and it's a
working order in process thank you
first point I'm absolutely confident
that this meeting is an occasion for
many many EU leaders to majorly clear
that they are ready to provide more
military support and we all understand
the urgency of this need for more
Military Support point one and point to
the EU enlargement process I am John
fine because uh we we observed the
recent weeks and Manchester Ukraine very
quickly demonstrated the ability to
implement and reforms that are extremely
important and to make progress it means
that we we know what will happen in the
following weeks Ukraine will continue to
implement reform that are needed point
one the commission will make a report
and the council will have to decide what
are the next steps by the end of the
year
the commission is indeed working very
closely with the Ukrainian government on
the progress in the candidate status and
the seven steps and of course these
seven steps and not more referring to
your question because we have agreed on
these ones
um it is impressive to see how highly
professional with enormous quality
Ukraine is advancing on doing the
necessary reforms and working on these
seven steps for example the adoption of
the anti-corruption strategy the
resumption of the high judicial Council
the New Media law or these are steps
absolutely in the right direction more
needs to be done but important is to
understand there is no rigid timeline it
is a merits-based process so it's up to
the candidate country how far and how
fast they reach the goals that are being
set indeed there will be an oral report
now in Spring but the big goal is
to show the progress and to show the
track record in the progress and the
reforms to the report the written report
enlargement report in fall that's our
common goal the commission is of course
supporting Ukraine as much as possible
and Advising as much as possible in this
question I think it's very helpful that
we have now the Secretariat in Brussels
and in Keith because from the very
beginning it was clear that when we move
forward now in fast recovery
repair later on in reconstruction that
Investments should be coupled with
reforms that pave the path towards the
European Union
Elizabeth from
Ukraine info yes please
hello colleagues first
Ukraine as well
uh
dear volada I would like to ask you a
question about our armed forces of
Ukraine oh
we you know that our
volunteers are armed forces corporate we
cooperate quite closely with the
European Council and also with European
Union
but unfortunately not
everybody in the European Union
sometimes feels uh you know that the
country is at War there are some
entertainment facilities working and
thank you for getting about the hell of
Bahamut at other places and I wanted to
ask you when do you feel the whole
country and the society will actually
start feeling that the countries at War
together with the Armed Forces
okay
thank you very much for this question
I think we shouldn't mix everything
together
it's very difficult to wage war for such
a long time
and we are very very grateful to Armed
Forces and not just those who are on the
front line
but of course we have a grateful to them
because they're giving their lives but
also those who are Waging War working
not just in the front line they work
they have to pay taxes people are
supporting the army so indeed People Are
People humans are humans and there are
people who are tired to work in this
regimes of course there are
psychological issues there are people
who already need Rehabilitation there
are those who are lost somebody close to
them their relatives there are those who
want to forget
that they are grieving people are humans
they're different and I think that's the
component of Our Lives we cannot treat
everybody the same way we can't say you
all absolutely must
uh people have to have a Consciousness
conscious of that they have to
understand it themselves there I agree
with you totally people have to
understand that unfortunately
the war continues
unfortunately
uh it depends from our unity and our
Unity will give the resilience to our
soldiers there are people who want to go
on holiday arrest there are occasion
there are people not there are
challenges but we are not talking about
millions of people who don't want to
support and of course it's not just our
case it happened during various Wars
therefore the information support is key
and the president has to share with his
own example how you should behave during
the war the journalists have to show
if somebody decides perhaps to go on
holiday rather than support a war effort
yes this is our common goal common work
that's all
I wanted to say and it's the question
the issue of dignity
and the issue of other challenges but
please don't forget we are all humans
and by the way those humans we are all
humans who manage to stop Russian
aggression and we are now at the most
important stage we have stopped it but
now we have to win and we can't do it
just by words saying oh why in the
martial law and we can't concentrate
everybody's attentions through the words
we have to work we have to give the
information we have to knock at every
door and we have to do it together
I feel that it's not just issues in
military or the information policy or
indeed the government I think these are
the key steps
but we are the Democratic state so we
have to understand we have to develop
and we are defending our democracy we
can't force people to well we are not
Russia that is the Paradox we are
fighting for the European values we want
to be the member of the European Union
so even when we fight we have to fight
with dignity and with those values thank
you
from answer yeah they're in the back
oops
um hello Mr President
um first of Allah
I have two questions if I may on
Ukraine's integration process in
European Union first according to
president Wonderland here you're making
good progress but you accept that
Ukraine will likely have to wait years
before it can be a full member of the EU
and that within Europe there are
different level of supports toward
Ukraine and secondly what kind of EU
would you like to see and contribute to
I have a closer Union where Brussels
takes most decisions with no vetoes
Union Union where nations are firmly in
the lead thank you so much
was it all to me or all these questions
were for me
[Applause]
um
well it's okay
and and Ursula said that we we I think I
heard maybe I wanted to hear by the way
I don't maybe we want too much but
anyway so uh
I think I heard that will will
after the recommendation the result
about our recommendations and and we can
start opening the dialogue about our
future
uh or in in EU yes and you know my
question is to everybody
to help everybody yes we we need Unity
in this case so and and that's why of
course we need the the this year we want
very much to motivate us and to motivate
by the way to motivate our army because
they you know they attacked by by
Russians and by all this aggression to
motivate we are fighting for and we need
these four and one of these very
important four of course sovereignty of
course Ukraine children homes and of
course membership
and that's why of course we need it
this year and this year Charles when I
say this year I mean this year I mean
there's
two two zero 23. I feel I feel very well
responsibility I get unanimity in the
European Council which will do our best
I have one more question uh because we
have to start at some point with
European Council again yes Effie from uh
from Euro News
uh thank you president and welcome to
Brussels so I would like to insist to
the Practical part of of all these
meetings so you mentioned fighter jets
but I would like to ask you how
satisfied are you by of the level of
delivery of weapons and Arms by the EU
so far and what would be your
expectations from today's meeting and I
mean is it just a high symbolism visit
or you expect to get some very concrete
promises for fighter jets or other stuff
by your EU counterparts and also for the
presidents uh do you see a common ground
for providing this kind of warplanes to
Ukraine uh being reached anytime soon
and is it still this a decision to be
taken at a new level thank you
foreign
thank you very much for the question
I haven't got the right I simply haven't
got the right to come back home without
the results
that depends on the partners and from me
personally and for me it's very
important that all the talks we conduct
can lead to the results should lead to
the result and perhaps that slightly
impertinent but that's not cynical
that's pragmatic point of view and I
have to believe there are no emotions
the emotions are left on the 24th of
February last year we are just pragmatic
for us to survive we need the weapons we
need these weapons and that's what I'm
talking about for us to survive we need
these Financial funds and I'm not trying
to hide behind the words when I say we
are defending our common values I'm
absolutely sure we are doing that and I
hope that you understand that when you
help Ukraine you're helping yourselves
and you have to make it in such a way
that later
you shouldn't understand it in a
practical way so that later you don't
have to defend yourselves
so please it's important to give this
assistance earlier this is my Approach
and let's see of course there are
positive signals concerning the
respective weapons we have got positive
signals that we hear each other and I
really want their signals to move to
concrete sounds to can concrete voice
the voice that is not afraid that Russia
will hear this voice
and I'm absolutely sure that the
countries of the European Union and
during this year moved from doubts but
have significantly moved to a more
grown-up approach more powerful approach
we need your powerful voice we need your
powerful concrete support
is foreign
military
child
um has described
um that the delivery of military
capability is not a decision taken at EU
level of the institutions but a
sovereign decision of the member states
of course there's a strong coordination
but and you have seen the living proof
of delivery of military capabilities but
everything else
is done and coordinated at the European
level so the 67 billion for the past are
symbol for that as I said we need to do
more and we will do more
um be it the economy be the integration
of the Ukrainian economy in the single
Market be it energy beat the solidarity
Lanes be it the support for the
ukrainians that are freeing Putin's
bombs and are in the European Union this
is all topics that are being pushed
forward including the sanctions on the
European level that we are working on
but the delivery of military
capabilities is a sovereign decision of
the member states
thank you to the three presidents
president zelenski to you and your team
safe travels
here we go
foreign
[Music]